molly dillon i'm here with bob bauer and
we wanted to take a few minutes to go
over with you
what we're seeing across the key states
that are
left outstanding most importantly i want
to share with all of you that
joe biden is on track to win this
election and he will be
the next president of the united states
so we believe we are on a clear
path to victory by this afternoon we
expect that the vice president will have
leads in states
that put him over 270 electoral votes
today the vice president will garner
more votes than any presidential
candidate in history
and we're still counting over 135
million votes
have been counted so far and the vice
president has received
69 million votes so far he has won over
50 percent
of the popular vote we are on track to
win in michigan
by more than donald trump did in 2016
to win in wisconsin by more than trump
did in 2016
to win in pennsylvania by more than
trump did in 2016.
and we flipped one of his states arizona
and congressional districts
nebraska too last night to add it on top
of that